We're in the last section
of test 6.
Section 9, page 743.
Problem number 1.
For which of the following
values of m will the value of
3m minus 1 be greater than 10?
So we add 1 to both sides.
3m is going to be
greater than 11.
Divide both sides by 3, and you
don't have to switch the
inequality because
3 is positive.
So you get m is going to
be greater than 11/3.
And 11/3, this is what?
This is equal to 3 and 2/3.
So anything greater than
3, really, any integer
greater than 3.
If you look at all the choices,
the only one that's
greater than 3 and 2/3
is choice A, 4.
Next problem.
If a times k is equal to k--
sorry, if a times k is equal
to a for all values of a,
what is the value of k?
And the reason why they have
to say all values of a is
because if a was 0, then that
would work for any k.
But if it's for all values of
k, you divide both sides of
this equation by a, you
get k is equal to a/a
which is equal to 1.
So k would have be equal
to 1, which is D.
And you knew that.
You didn't have to
do any algebra.
If I multiply something times
some number and I get the
original thing, that number's
going to be 1.
Problem 3.
Image.
So let me draw what
they've drawn.
So I have one parallel
line like that.
I'm assuming they're parallel,
because they look parallel in
the picture.
And then there's a line that
comes down like this.
There's another line that
goes up like that.
And what do they tell
us about it?
They tell us that this is
x degrees right here.
This is z degrees.
This is y degrees.
This is line l.
This is line m.
In the figure above,
l is parallel to m.
If x is equal to 80 degrees-- so
this is 80 degrees-- and y
is equal to 70 degrees, what
is the value of z?
So the trick here is just to
see the opposite angles.
In fact, the information that
they're parallel lines is
actually just extra information
to start making
you do corresponding
angles and all that
kind of fancy stuff.
Which you could do.
But the really easy thing is to
realize that x, this angle,
is the same thing as this
angle, which is
going to be 80 degrees.
Right?
Because they're opposite angles
of intersecting lines.
And this-- if that's 70,
then this angle is
also going to be 70.
And now 80 plus 70 plus z has to
equal 180, because they're
all in the same triangle
together.
So 80 plus 70 plus z
is equal to 180.
150 plus z is equal to 180.
Subtract 150 from both
sides, you get z
is equal to 30 degrees.
The other way you could have
done it is you could have used
the information about
the parallel lines.
And you could have said, well,
the corresponding angle here
is here, so that this
is also 80 degrees.
And you could have said the
corresponding angle here is
also here, so this
is 70 degrees.
And then you could have said
all three of these are
supplementary, and that they
would have to add up to 180.
And you'd get z equals
30 either way.
And that is choice A.
Next problem.
Problem 4.
The scenic route from Mia's
home to her office is 5
kilometers longer than
the direct route.
So I'll call S for scenic.
S is equal to the direct
route plus 4.
The scenic route is 4 miles
longer than the direct route,
or 4 kilometers.
When she goes by the scenic
route and returns by the
direct route, the round
trip is 35 kilometers.
So that means what?
The distance of the scenic route
plus the distance of the
direct route is equal
to 35 kilometers.
How many kilometers is
the direct route?
So we want to solve for this.
So this top equation, we can
rewrite this as S minus D is
equal to 4.
And actually just to make
things-- well, let me write
that down right here.
So you get S minus
D is equal to 4.
And we can multiply this
equation by negative 1, so you
cancel out the S's instead of
the D's, but since it's so
convenient already, let's just
cancel out the D's and solve
for the scenic route.
The S's.
So this is just a
system with two
equations and two unknowns.
So let's add these
two equations.
So you get 2S-- D plus
D is 0-- is equal to
35 plus 4 is 39.
The numbers look strange.
The scenic distance is 39/2.
Right?
That's 39/2 kilometers.
And what is that equal to?
If I were to write that
as a mixed number.
Let's see.
38 is-- that's 19 and
1/2 kilometers.
A little less than
20 kilometers.
That's the scenic route.
The direct route is 4 less
than that, right?
We said the scenic route is 4
more than the direct route.
So the direct route is going
to be that minus 4.
So what's 19 minus 4?
It's 15, and then you still
have that half there.
15 and 1/2 kilometers.
And I don't see that
choice there, so I
must have made a mistake.
Let me do it here, just
to see where-- I
don't see that choice.
The scenic route from Mia's
home to her office is 5
kilometers longer than
the direct route.
Right.
The scenic route-- we could even
say scenic route minus--
oh, sorry, it's 5 kilometers
longer.
Sorry.
This is 5.
That was my mistake.
5 kilometers longer.
Scenic minus direct is 5.
They normally don't give weird
numbers like that.
So this is 5.
This is 40.
This is 40/2.
This is 20.
Hope I'm not confusing you.
And then if you're going to be
5 less than 20, it's going to
be 15 kilometers, right?
I hope you see what
I just did.
I wrote 4 kilometers longer
instead of 5.
That was my mistake, which
you should avoid.
Next problem.
Let me switch colors.
I think that yellow induces
careless mistakes.
5.
A complete cycle of a traffic
light takes 80 seconds.
During each cycle, the light
is green for 40 seconds.
Amber-- I guess that's red--
amber for 10 seconds.
Oh, I guess amber is yellow.
I don't know my colors.
And red for 30 seconds.
And the whole cycle
takes 80 seconds.
If you add those up.
At a randomly chosen time, what
is the probability that
the light will not be red?
So the probability that the
light will not be red is the
probability that it's going
to be green or amber.
And it's green or amber for 40
plus 10, for 50 seconds out of
a total of 80 seconds, right?
So the probability that when
you randomly walk up to the
light, that it's going to be
green or amber-- or not red--
is going to be 50 seconds.
50/80, which is 5/8.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 6.
For a certain hot water heater,
the increase in
heating expenses is directly
proportional to the increase
in the water temperature
setting.
If heating expenses increase
by $24 when the water
temperature is increased by
20 degrees Fahrenheit-- so
expense goes up by 24 when
temperature is increased by 20
degrees Fahrenheit.
By how much will heating
expenses increase when the
water temperature setting is
increased by 15 degrees
Fahrenheit?
So this is just a
ratio problem.
So you say, well, the expenses
go up $24 when we have a
20-degree increase
in temperature.
So then how many dollars will
it increase when you have a
15-degree increase?
The denominator in both cases
was the change in temperature.
And then this is the
change in expense.
The triangle means
change, right?
So you just have to make sure
that the ratios are consistent
and let's just multiply.
You get 20-- actually, and so
we don't have to get big
numbers, let me reduce
this fraction.
Divide the top and the bottom.
This is the same thing as
6/5 is equal to x/15.
This is easier to
multiply now.
You get 5x is equal
to 15 times 6.
Divide both sides by 5.
You get x is equal to 15
times 6 divided by 5.
That's 3, that's 1, that's 18.
So the change in expense will
be $18, and that's choice B.
See you in the next video.